[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 ya
está lista conmigo en el estudio más
romeros a la mar bienvenida a feliz
jueves vamos a empezar en la 2 porque se
confirma que hay tres especies de
murciélagos con virus muy parecidos al
que provoca el hobbit 19 que provocó
esta pandemia así es es un hallazgo del
instituto pastor que nos acerca un poco
más a entender cómo empezó esta pandemia
de kobe 19 que llevamos dos años
sufriendo se encontraron en el norte de
laos de la península de indochina un
lugar que de hecho está muy cerca del
lugar o es de lugares densamente
poblados eso puede explicar parte de
esta historia y encontraron la presencia
de una serie de virus también
coronavirus muy parecidos al sars co2
estamos hablando de un parecido genético
entre el 95 y el 96 8% es decir que
tienen una línea un genoma muy muy
parecido al del sars co2 algo
especialmente destacable es que estos
virus cuentan con un receptor que se
llama hace 2 que es como una llave que
permite entrar a las células humanas e
infectar las en estos virus es
prácticamente igual este receptor que
también en él cap 2 porque es importante
por un lado pues para poder tener
pendientes qué puede pasar en el futuro
futuras pandemias futuras crisis
prepararnos también para alejar una
hipótesis que ya es distante no sobre el
origen del laboratorio del cobat 19 y
por último también pues porque perdona
un poco a los pangolines de esa
responsabilidad que le estábamos dando
al inicio de la pandemia la sopa la
famosa sopa de murciélago mar pero ahora
volvemos al presente el commit 19 la
compañía by once que presentó su
producto para poder producir vacunas
como la afa y ser pero esto en el
continente africano una muy buena
noticia es una buena noticia aunque
tiene ciertos matices se hizo ayer con
mucho bombo y platillo' porque de hecho
también está enmarcada en esta cumbre
que estábamos hablando entre los líderes
de la unión africana y de la unión
europea el director de baión tec
recordemos que es la compañía que
desarrolló la vacuna con facer explicaba
así cómo podía funcionar este nuevo
producto este nuevo diseño
y queremos producir rápidamente vacunas
de arn mensajero de alta calidad en el
continente africano hemos desarrollado
una solución técnica con este fin
llamado bio tener
permite producir varios productos con
aire en mensajeros según el protocolo de
seguridad
entonces raúl se trata de como una
especie de contenedores que se pueden
mover fácilmente que allí se puede
producir estas vacunas de agarre de
mensajero contra el cob en 19 pero
también a futuro pueden servir contra
otras enfermedades y la idea es que
empiecen a funcionar a mediados y a
finales de este año y así ayudar a
extender la vacunación en el continente
africano que sabemos que es la región
más rezagada en este sentido sin embargo
pues este anuncio como te decía ha
recibido varias críticas aún por un lado
críticas a la unión europea y a los
países que han defendido que no se
liberen las patentes en esta cumbre
además que estamos esperando
probablemente van a ver nuevas promesas
de ayuda al desarrollo ya la salud de
áfrica entonces es importante recordar
en que vamos por ahora se ha repartido
el cese por ciento de las vacunas que
había prometido la unión europea al
continente africano en 2021 es decir que
no se ha cumplido con todo lo que se
había dicho y esto teniendo ya una
promesa de 450 millones de dosis para
2022 una cifra que triplica la que se
había prometido por otro lado también se
critica a las farmacéuticas en este caso
a bayonne tec porque pues al final no
hay manera más rápida de distribuir
vacunas que liberar las patentes y la
farmacéutica digamos que sigue
insistiendo en lograr maneras de que se
desarrollen su propia vacuna sin liberar
y sin compartir esta información marc un
nuevo estudio muestra que los
medicamentos contaminan los principales
ríos del mundo así es no hay región que
se escape en todos los continentes en
todas las regiones del mundo hay ríos
donde se han encontrado por rastros de
medicamentos vemos que los principales
que se hallaron son el paracetamol por
ejemplo nicotina cafeína pero sobre todo
medicamentos contra la epilepsia y
contra la diabetes que riesgos para la
salud tiene esto pues por ejemplo
desarrollar más resistencia a los
antibióticos habíamos hablado de es una
resistencia que ya tenemos y que pueda
aumentar por esta contamina y además
pues es importante recordar que la
mayoría de estos ríos los más
contaminados se encontraron en los
países de ingresos bajos y medianos
vamos a américa latina' repasar cómo
estaba esta situación aquí según este
estudio de la universidad de york vemos
que las aguas de la paz en bolivia
fueron las más contaminadas de la región
las segundas en todo el mundo le
siguieron un montevideo buenos aires
también en general son ríos que están
atravesando capitales de los países y en
menor medida pues guayaquil cali en
colombia santiago de chile- todas estas
ciudades que ven en este mapa estaban en
la mitad superior de ríos contaminados
del mundo según el estudio es decir que
ninguna escapa al riesgo triste noticia
mar y terminamos con algo de esperanza
en somalia así es un poco saber cómo la
sociedad civil a veces sale al rescate
en situaciones complicadas los
periodistas de reuters pudieron visitar
el único banco de sangre pública que
existe en somalia se creó después de un
atentado en mogadiscio en la capital en
2017 donde murieron 500 personas y
muchas de estas vidas se hubieran podido
salvar si hubieran tenido acceso a
transfusiones de sangre sin embargo más
allá de los atentados esto también es
importante para de enfermos crónicos
mujeres en el momento del parto y es muy
importante recordar que esto funciona
con trabajo voluntario es el único
hospital que da sangre en mogadicio y en
todo somalia más allá de pequeñas
reservas en los hospitales privados esto
es lo que decía el fundador de este
banco
somos voluntarios aquí en el banco de
sangre servimos a la gente que necesita
sangre de manera urgente cada día
siempre trabajamos y ayudamos todo lo
que podemos y entregamos sangre tanto a
los hospitales públicos como privados
sabemos que una unidad de sangre donada
puede llegar a salvar tres vidas
entonces es muy importante celebrar que
haya gente que se dedica a tratar de
salvar todas estas vidas porque no todo
es malicia los seres humanos así al
final tenemos algo de bondad aunque no
siempre se ve amar muchísimas gracias
entonces por toda la información de
salud nos vemos mañana con más vamos a
ir un directo hasta parís